saluant un ça va non qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
alors non je crois que fait une overdose
une overdose
oui une overdose à tes blagues sur moi
dans les intros [ __ ] t'es con il est
bon d'accord pardon parce que moi je
vais faire plus attention mais rigole
pas avec ça sérieux client tu as fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une overdose
vous voyez sûrement ce que c'est vous
êtes peut-être même une idée plus ou
moins précise de ce à quoi ça peut
ressembler une idée que vous êtes fait
en entendant des histoires qu'on vous a
raconté ou plus probablement en
regardant des scènes de films ou de
séries
[Musique]
du coup en fonction ce que vous avez vu
et entendu vous vous êtes fabriquer un
imaginaire autour de l'overdose
ce n'est pas un souci en soi mais si
l'idée c'est de savoir vraiment quoi
faire si on tombe sur quelqu'un qui fait
une overdose l'imaginaire on sait bien
mais la réalité c'est mieux alors dans
la vraie vie une overdose c'est quoi à
quoi ça ressemble déjà overdose dans
l'absolu c'est le terme anglais en
français on y surdose et c'est la dose
excessive d'un médicament ou d'un
stupéfiant une drogue si vous voulez
susceptible d'entraîner la mort par
extension on emploie souvent ce terme
pour désigner le fait d'avoir pris cette
fameuse clause est soit dans cette mort
soit de vraiment pas en est loin mais ça
recouvre tout un tas de réalités très
différentes parfois là forcément grave
parfois très ne serait ce que parce que
cette dose c'est pas la même pour tout
le monde
suivant votre état de santé votre
attitude des produits et suivant la
teneur en drogue qui peut varier
beaucoup d'une substance à l'autre du
coup vous avez compris une overdose
c'est pas ce truc hyper clair précis
hyper bien définis s'est passé c'est que
l'image que vous étiez fait dans les
films pour la bonne raison que ya pas
une forme de bordeaux dans la plainte ça
dépend de plein de trucs de ce que la
personne a pris déjà parce que les
surdoses de chaque drogue elles ont pas
les mêmes conséquences
sans même parler de tous les produits
plus ou moins toxiques qui sont utilisés
pour couper tout ça et qu'ils peuvent
eux même avoir des effets secondaires et
c'est encore différent si la personne a
pris plusieurs drogues ou des drogues
plus de l'alcool ou des drogues et des
médicaments
mais on sait qu'avec la cocaïne par
exemple le risque c'est des problèmes au
niveau du coeur qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à l'arrêt cardiaque
pareil avec certaines drogues de
synthèse comme la mpm a avec en plus une
déshydratation
on sait aussi que les opiacés comme la
morphine ou l'héroïne par exemple ça
peut entraîner des pauses voire des
arrêts respiratoires qui au bout du
compte se termineront l'arrêt cardiaque
bon mais encore une fois il ya plein
d'autres produits ne serait-ce que
l'alcool parce que c'est une drogue
légale mais une drogue qui peuvent
entraîner plein d'autres problèmes
giteau un autre pomme et en a donc
concrètement vous êtes en soirée vous
voyez quelqu'un de sa valeur ne pas
aller bien
vous faites quoi d'abord ne paniquez pas
alors ça va peut-être l'air paradoxal de
dire ça mais on est passé d'une époque
où on laissait les gens dans le coma
dans un coin sans faire attention à des
cas où maintenant on amène des gens aux
urgences juste parce qu'ils ont envie de
vomir c'est des professionnels qui me
l'ont dit donc il faut être attentif aux
autres et savoir quoi faire pour pas
faire n'importe quoi et pour être
efficace
la première chose à faire c'est de
vérifier l'état dans lequel se trouve
vraiment la personne qui vous semblent
pas aller bien donc pour être très clair
là on parle ni plus ni moins que de
reflex classique de premiers secours
si vous êtes formés mais vous savez un
vous vérifier son état de conscience ta
respiration si son coeur bat comme on
vous a appris et en fonction de ce que
vous trouverez bas et alès massage
cardiaque dont vous connaissez tout ça
puisque vous êtes formés et si vous
n'êtes pas formés et bien formés vous je
vous mets tous les liens utiles dans la
description de la vidéo
en attendant vous pouvez retourner
regarder mes vidéos sur les gestes qui
sauvent
mais de toute façon fort mais vous c'est
important et ça nous servira dans plein
d'autres situations
c'est important aussi d'essayer de
communiquer avec la personne qui va pas
bien pour vérifier son état de
conscience donc mais aussi pour essayer
de comprendre ce qu'elle ressent ce
qu'elle a pris 6 et la première fois ci
elle est habituée etc
c'est des informations qui vont être
importantes pour la suite parce que bien
sûr il va falloir appeler les secours
le samu au 15 les pompiers au 18 ou le
numéro d'appel d'urgence européen au 112
soit pour qu'ils interviennent soit pour
qu'il vous donne au moins des conseils
sur ce qu'il faut faire
alors je sais si on parle d'overdose on
parle de drogue et vous avez peut-être
peur de voir la police débarquer là
c'est entre vous et votre conscience
mais il a quand même quelqu'un qui va
pas bien et qui a besoin d'aidé
donc appelé au moins pour expliquer ce
qui se passe et qu'on vous explique qu a
faire sur la base de ce qu'on va vous
dire et en fonction du cas surveiller la
personne rassurer la si besoin est
appliqué les conseils qu'on va vous
donner
alors je me doute que vous vous posez la
question si la personne va à l'hôpital
est ce qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose
de précis qui peut être fait en cas
d'overdose
bah oui évidemment déjà corrigé tous les
problèmes entraînés par la surdose une
perfusion pour réhydrater parce que
c'est pas toujours possible non pas
prudent de
faire voir une assistance respiratoire
et des médicaments pour le coeur
par exemple il ya aussi dans certains
cas des traitements vraiment spécifique
des antidotes si vous voulez comme
contre les opiacés par exemple permettre
de reprendre une respiration normale
d'ailleurs ces traitements ils sont
disponibles en pharmacie et les secours
les ont aussi avec le club ça se
présente sous forme d'un spray qu'on
envoie dans le met mais ça ça va
disparaître ou sous forme d'injections
une piqûre alors non pas comme ça mais
en tout cas sachez que oui il ya des
choses qui peuvent être faites et que
comme d'habitude plutôt c'est fait dieu
sait s'il faut retenir un truc de tout
ça c'est il ya autant de surdoses de
situation donc fait comme pour n'importe
quel malaise et formez vous aux premiers
secours
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout porté vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]